the soundtrack tonight is a soviet one
but the dream to move away from
soviet-era policing
and this soviet-style regime last night
locals tied the red and white flag
to these railings and today at three
o'clock the police came
uh and ordered municipal workers to cut
them painstakingly off what a waste of
police time but it goes to show
what an important symbol of this
revolution this red and white flag is
anna kovale is a volunteer collecting
donated food and supplies to bring to
people in detention
she wears the red and white proudly
showing me the socks knitted with love
by the nation's grandmothers
but she says the system's changed now
you can only deliver these care packages
once a week
she thinks the prison authorities are
doing their best to make things
difficult
thursday is day at ocrestina prison
and that same day they'll start moving
people to baranovici and rodina prisons
and many parents come with parcels for
their children and can't give them to
them
so they come queue up and find that
their child was moved to another
detention center
an hour earlier
there have been 15 000 people detained
these past two and a half months
and still they come out every saturday
for the women's march
and then the main event on sunday the
police have threatened to use live
ammunition now against the protesters is
that going to stop you
i guess no i guess no because there are
too many of
us they can't kill everyone they can't
shoot
everyone they they can't arrest
everybody do you think they'll do it
uh you know many people have been
arrested by now
even among my friends there are some
people who have been arrested
who have been beaten up at the protests
but we are too many and
they arrest one one person and 10 more
will come out instead
previous sundays have looked like this
today promises to be no different
president lukashenko is not backing down
but neither are his people letting up
dynamagne sky news minsk